we met not too long ago and we were just
chatting and i was like i've got to have
this guy on the show you're you're a big
star very cool and i was first taken
with the hair
what are you doing here the hair we've
both gone a different way mine goes up
like a french dessert
you were like you know king of the
jungle
lion you've got this thing going on it's
amazing we're going for a bit of a
tarzan look it's cool yeah it's cool
what i've noticed is that that's okay
feel free to go crazy applaud my hair
please while you talk i'm going to braid
it yeah
we just start all dishes
i just pictured a very creepy handmade
chapter
i'm curious because you wet your hair
and then a lot of guys in wrestling uh
are they get sweaty but they're also
coated in oil how do you guys get a grip
on each other when you're wrestling you
you look you both look like uh very
slippery sausages
[Laughter]
how do you get how do you grab a guy
it's a slippery situation um it
sometimes it's tough you know for me
it's strategy it's uh you know stay off
me don't don't get a hold but uh there's
actually a situation in wrestlemania my
very first wrestlemania um i was pretty
much whipping sheamus who's another he
has the ginger hair and it's famous yeah
his whole thing he's been on the show
he's a big irish guy sheamus humongous
irish guy so i'm beating him up i'm
whipping him in and just
oil takes over
and it felt like a cliffhanger type
matrix slo-mo situation where he's like
oh no
no not today any other day except for
wrestlemania but by the grace of god
somehow we just came back together and
you know finished the movement but
a little bit of a panic there yeah
because he could have slipped and slid
off out of the ring and like out the
door of the stadium
[Applause]
all the way to times square but that's
the thing you know when you're putting
all this oil on you're thinking you're
looking cool
looking like a badass you know what you
do hopefully you don't slip away from me
you you can be a very intimidating guy
you will sometimes roar in the ring
just before you execute
the spear your move is the spear which
is one of my favorite moves in wrestling
take a look at this it's absolutely
incredible
you launched yourself
that's what i do for a living right
bizarre but when did you i love that
they know it's coming because you do
that roar no one does a better roar than
you and then you launch when did you
learn that launch when did you start
doing that well you know i played
football from the age of seven so for me
it's an open field tackle and it just
made sense you know i played college
football a hiccup of pro football and
then uh you know once i transferred from
uh the gridiron to the the wrestling
ring right it was a no-brainer uh you
know i've been i've been hitting people
wide open since i was seven years old so
why stop now you know you just you were
this size when you were seven i was
actually a funny i wore a size 15 when i
was 15. so
wow yeah and this was before the
internet and you could order shoes and
clothes and you didn't have to leave in
amazon and all this stuff so that is a
bit of a sensitive subject right yeah i
that's why i brought it up
i must want to hear that rule
i'll behave